* Sanfte Melodie: "Moon River" *
Isabel Sahli war 14 Jahre alt,
als sich ihr Leben völlig veränderte.
Es war der erste schöne Sommertag.
Wir hatten die Idee,
bei einem Freund zu grillen.
Er hatte bei sich vor dem Haus
eine offene Grillschale,
in der wir ein Feuerchen machten.
Doch es ging dann
nicht wirklich vorwärts.
Dann hatte er die Idee,
Brandbeschleuniger reinzukippen.
Das gab eine grosse Stichflamme,
und ich stand gerade - eigent-
lich nicht sehr nahe am Feuer,
aber wohl an einem dummen Ort.
Vis-à-vis.
Dann hat mich
diese Stichflamme mich erfasst
und meine Kleider haben gebrannt.
Ich erinnere mich noch gut
an diesen Moment.
Es war sehr schockierend.
Ich spürte keine Schmerzen
oder so.
Das ist das, was viele Leute fragen.
Ich glaube, da ist man
derart in einem Schockzustand,
man merkt das gar nicht.
Der Freund hat sehr gut reagiert
und mir einen Pool gezeigt,
in dem es Wasser
vom letzten Jahr hatte.
Da bin ich reingesprungen,
und das war, glaube ich,
sehr gut, um die Haut zu kühlen.
Dann haben sie
die Ambulanz angerufen.
Ich kam raus, mir war kalt,
zitterte am ganzen Körper.
Ich sah, wie an den Händen
Hautfetzen runterhingen und so.
Und ich hatte natürlich
schon einen grossen Schock:
"Was ist das genau?"
Ich kannte mich nicht
so gut mit Verbrennungen aus.
Dann brachten sie mir eine Decke,
weil mir kalt war.
Und wir warteten,
bis die Ambulanz kam.
Nach der Erstversorgung flog ich
dann per Helikopter nach Zürich.
* Spannende Klänge,
regelmässiges Piepen *
Im Kinderspital kam Isabel
sofort auf die Intensivstation
und wurde
in ein künstliches Koma versetzt.
* Spannende Klänge,
regelmässiges Piepen *
Es gibt die Hierarchie der Probleme.
Das Überleben ist
selbstverständlich das Wichtigste.
D.h., die ganze therapeutische
Ausrichtung in der ersten Woche
geht nur darum,
sicherzustellen, dass er überlebt.
Und in dieser Woche wird auch klar,
welche Möglichkeiten man hat,
in diesem engen Kostüm
auch noch ein gutes funktionelles
und kosmetisches Ergebnis schon
in der Erstbehandlung zu erzielen.
Das sind eigentlich ...
Das formiert sich
innerhalb der ersten zwei Wochen.
Das ist für mein Team und mich
der schwierigste,
aber auch spannendste Anteil.
Dort wird klar:
Wie lange gehen wir mit dem Kind?
Wie lange sind wir in Lebensgefahr?
Was können wir uns
an zusätzlichen Operationen leisten,
um z.B. ein besseres
kosmetisches Ergebnis zu erreichen?
Das wird alles
in den ersten zwei Wochen klar.
Clemens Schiestl leitet
das Zentrum für brandverletzte Kinder
des Kinderspitals Zürich.
Mit seinem Team behandelt er pro Jahr
bis zu 30 Kinder mit starken
Verbrennungen oder Verbrühungen.
* Er spricht holländisch. *
Guus verbrannte sich
im Sommer 2014 schwer.
Der Unfall passierte bei
einer Ferienplausch-Veranstaltung.
Noch muss er deshalb Tag und Nacht
einen Kompressionsanzug tragen -
den sog. Jobst.
Grüezi wohl.
- Grüezi.
Hallo. So, jetzt gehen wir rein.
- Ja.
Guus lebt erst seit
zweieinhalb Monaten wieder daheim.
Regelmässig muss er
ins Kinderspital zur Kontrolle.
Mit dabei sind eine Pflegeberaterin,
Physiotherapeutinnen,
Ergotherapeutin,
Psychologe und ein Chirurg.
Gell, Guus,
wir fangen jetzt langsam an.
Wir fangen im Gesicht an.
Sei also so gut
und zieh die Kopfmaske aus!
Und das ist jetzt die,
die er Tag und Nacht anhat?
Nein, die Maske ist für den Tag.
Und nachts hat er ... Nichts mehr?
Ein Jäckchen mit dem Kopf dran
und ein Silikonteil.
(Flüsternd)
Okay, mach mal den Mund auf!
Prima, alles klar.
Okay, kannst wieder zumachen,
ist gut.
Okay, prima. Gut.
Jetzt fangen wir mit dem an,
was sich direkt ändert.
Physio und Ergo
haben wir besprochen, oder?
Und jetzt müssen wir
über die Anzüge reden.
Markus, da bist du wichtig,
weil die Anzüge in gewisser Weise
auch einen Schutz für Guus
darstellen.
D.h., wir würden jetzt
auf nur noch die Hälfte des Tages -
d.h., Tag oder Nacht, das kann Guus
selber entscheiden - reduzieren.
Dann sehen wir ihn
nach diesem Monat wieder, gucken,
ob es irgendwelche
Verschlechterungen gegeben hat,
und wenn es keine
wird der Anzug ganz weggelassen.
Oh, wow.
Es gibt immer zwei Seiten.
Das eine ist, dass man diesen
Schutz, den dieser Anzug darstellt,
nicht mehr hat.
Dann sehen alle die Haut,
und das ist für einige Kinder
ein bisschen eine Belastung.
Wir können das einfach herausfinden
und Guus einfach fragen:
Was lässt du zuerst weg,
den Tag oder die Nacht?
Den Tag.
- Ja, dann ist es kein Problem.
Wenn er
zuerst den Tagjobst weglässt,
hat er keine Angst
vor den anderen Kindern und so.
Und dann wird es
wahrscheinlich gut gehen, oder?
Machst du dir Sorgen
wegen der Reaktionen?
Nicht?
Als er wieder zu Hause war und
die Schule wieder angefangen hat,
hatte er den Kopfjobst
eine Weile nicht an.
Die Kinder haben ihn schon
ohne Kopfjobst gesehen.
Von daher
ist es mit dem Gesicht schon okay.
Okay, also dann, Guus,
lassen wir den Anzug tagsüber weg.
Ist gut? Und nur noch nachts.
Guus hat noch eine Frage.
Wie machen wir es dann,
wenn ich keinen Jobst mehr habe
und nicht überall Schatten ist?
Es ist einfach so:
Es gibt diese Hüte mit der breiten
Krempe oder diese Sonnenschutzteile,
die so schräg nach unten gehen,
die müsstest du tragen,
wenn du direkt an der Sonne bist.
Es ist nur diesen Sommer so.
Danach - im Gegenteil -
wollen wir zwar nicht,
dass er sich
der prallen Sonne aussetzt,
aber dass er sich bräunt.
Ohne Bändel unten, okay?
- Genau.
Sehr gut, prima.
* Guus brüllt. *
Gut, okay. So.
Jetzt müssen wir
das T-Shirt ausziehen und das hier.
Die Handschuhe auch. Gut.
Jetzt die Arme
noch einmal nach oben halten!
Auf 50 % seiner Hautoberfläche hatte
Guus Verbrennungen dritten Grades.
Das Team im Kinderspital
musste viel Haut transplantieren.
Das meiste waren gesunde Hautstücke
von seinem Kopf und den Beinen.
Weisst du noch, wo die Haut ist,
die neue aus dem Labor?
Ein Hautstück ist im Labor gewachsen.
Ganz weich, ganz glatt.
Das ist normale Haut
und das die andere.
Zum ersten Mal wird
eine aus patienteneigenen Zellen
hergestellte Haut
am Patienten verwendet.
Seit 15 Jahren arbeiten Forscher
und Ärzte an dieser Haut.
Guus nimmt an einer Studie teil.
Abschliessende Resultate
liegen zurzeit noch nicht vor.
Komm, komm! Komm raus! Komm!
Komm!
* Muhen *
Komm, komm!
Komm! So, komm!
Isabel wohnt bei ihren Eltern auf
einem Bauernhof in der Nähe von Bern.
Sie ist das jüngste
von drei Geschwistern.
* Muhen *
Ihr Vater besuchte sie trotz
der vielen Arbeit auf dem Bauernhof
so häufig wie möglich.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Das erste Buch.
- Nummer 1.
Wie hast du das gemacht?
- Das war ein schönes Foto.
In der ersten Zeit nach dem Unfall
schlief Isabel meistens.
Deshalb brachte ihre Schwester Andrea
ein Buch mit leeren Seiten
ins Spital.
Die Besucher haben für Isabel
gezeichnet und gedichtet.
"Du machst das wirklich gut."
"Isabel, dein Papi
zieht vor dir den Hut."
Frau Cortés ...
- Das fühlt sich so lustig an.
Ist es das, was du
jeweils auf den Narben hattest?
Dahinter sind drei kleine,
süsse, rot-weisse Kätzchen.
Ja, du wolltest sie unbedingt sehen.
"Foto folgt."
Isabel liess sich
nach dem Unfall nicht fotografieren,
deshalb sind dies
wichtige Erinnerungen
an die sechs Monate im Kinderspital.
Meistens eine schwere Zeit.
Ich hatte
grosse Wundheilungsstörungen,
das Zeug ist nicht mehr zugewachsen.
Auch auf der gesunden Haut
gab es Probleme.
Die Kopfhaut
ist nicht gut zugewachsen.
Dann war einfach nicht mehr gut.
Ich konnte nicht mehr essen.
Das Essen war mir so verleidet.
Ich nahm stark ab,
brauchte eine Ernährungsberatung.
Ich konnte einfach nicht mehr.
Es ist so,
man stand morgens auf ...
Ich hatte so viele Therapien,
die Schule ...
Ich musste überstreckt liegen
wegen der Narben.
Ich hatte eine Zeit lang
fast keine Zeit mehr für Besuch.
Das war so ein strenger Tagesablauf.
Ich musste immer essen.
Ich konnte aber nicht essen.
Sie drohten mir, wenn ich noch
so viel abnehmen würde,
brauchte ich wieder eine Magensonde.
Das wäre auch sehr schlimm gewesen.
Es ging eine Zeit lang
nur noch bergab.
Da fragt man sich:
"Wann hört das endlich auf?"
"Wann geht es wieder weiter?"
Isabel musste
Unmengen an Kalorien zu sich nehmen,
denn die Heilung von Brandver-
letzungen verbraucht viel Energie.
Irgendwann
kam ihre Kraft wieder zurück.
Es seien die Liebe und Geborgenheit
der Familie gewesen,
die ihr halfen.
Ihre Schwester stand damals vor
der Ausbildung zur Primarlehrerin.
Sie half den Eltern,
wo immer es ging.
Das war schon schwierig.
Man fragte sich:
"Wo kann man sie unterstützen?"
"Wo muss man sich selber abgrenzen?"
Ich merkte:
"Bald beginnt meine Ausbildung,
ich muss auf mich Acht geben."
Aber trotzdem
will man zu Hause unterstützen
und Sachen abnehmen auf dem Hof.
Das war schwierig, aber es ging.
Meine schönen Schuhe.
Die Eltern von Guus leben bereits
seit sieben Jahren getrennt.
Sie teilen sich
die Betreuung der Söhne.
Guus besuchte vorletzten Sommer
mit seinem älteren Bruder Koen
eine Ferienplausch-Veranstaltung, bei
der etwas katastrophal schieflief.
Den genauen Unfallverlauf will
die Familie nicht veröffentlichen.
Aus rechtlichen Gründen.
Das ist der Film.
Dieses, oder? Auch.
Ah, die zwei, ja.
Warum sieht man
die Hände nicht mehr?
Sie sind ganz eingepackt.
Da kannst du etwas grösser machen.
Das war der Monitor für das Herz,
Sauerstoff und alles.
Das hier sind die Medikamente.
Und das war ...
- Don't touch!
Ja.
Da war dieser Arm operiert worden.
Don't touch!
- Dr. Schiestl schrieb drauf.
Ich war hier zu Hause, füllte gerade
das Schwimmbad für die Jungs.
Da wurde ich
von der Polizei angerufen.
Von der Kantonspolizei Zürich.
Erst haben sie mir Probefragen
gestellt: "Wie ist Ihre Adresse?"
"Haben Sie Kinder?"
Und ich: "Ja, zwei Jungs."
"Wo sind die Kinder jetzt?" Ich:
"Die sind bei einem Ferienplausch."
Dann hat er gesagt: "Okay,
sie sind Herr van Eck, das stimmt."
"Ihre Kinder sind jetzt bei mir,
und wir fahren
ins Kinderspital in Zürich."
Das war quasi,
wie ich das erfahren habe.
Dann kommt man so
in einen Automatikmodus:
Ich stieg sofort ins Auto
und fuhr ins Kispi.
Natürlich rief ich noch
die Mutter der Kinder an.
Sie war selbst auch
von der Polizei angerufen worden.
Dann im Kispi ein,
sah den ältesten Sohn
und hörte, dass der andere
auf der Notstation ist.
* Spannende Klänge,
regelmässiges Piepen *
Zwei Tage lag Guus auf der
Intensivstation im künstlichen Koma.
* Spannende Klänge,
regelmässiges Piepen *
Zwei Tage war unklar,
ob er überleben würde.
* Spannende Klänge,
regelmässiges Piepen *
Möchtest du noch ...
Guus und sein älterer Bruder Koen
verbringen viel Zeit gemeinsam.
Sie waren auch zusammen,
als der Unfall passierte.
Guus wurde verbrannt.
Koen
hatte unsichtbare seelische Wunden.
Sie hatten keine Möglichkeit,
miteinander zu reden.
Doch Koen fand einen Weg,
mit seinem Bruder, der im Koma lag,
zu kommunizieren.
* Koen singt "Oh My Darling
Clementine" auf Holländisch. *
Guus kann nicht reagieren.
Wir sahen am Monitor,
dass der Puls nach oben ging.
Der merkte sehr wohl,
dass der Bruder da war und sang.
Kinder haben manchmal
einen Umgang mit Dingen,
den haben wir Erwachsenen
nicht mehr.
Keiner würde sich trauen, schnur-
stracks auf den Bruder zuzugehen,
der im künstlichen Koma liegt,
die Hand zu nehmen und zu singen.
So.
Dreh dich mal kurz!
Tamara Schmieds Unfall
ist zwei Jahre her.
Sie ist wieder gesund.
Doch ihre versehrte Haut
muss nach wie vor
gut vor der starken Sommersonne
geschützt werden.
Schau mal!
Zeig mal!
- Nein.
Schau mich bitte kurz an, Tamara!
Schaust du mich an?
Danke.
* Ein Baby brabbelt. *
Wo ist Thomas?
Thomas?
Tamara hat sich
mit eineinhalb Jahren verbrüht.
Das ist die häufigste Brandverletzung
bei Kindern.
Tamara, Mami erzählte uns,
dass du einen Unfall hattest,
bei dem du dir
ganz fest wehgetan hast.
Weisst du noch,
was da passiert ist?
Wo?
Was hast du hier gemacht? Hier.
Verbrennung.
Und was hast du gemacht,
dass du dich verbrannt hast?
Ausgeleert.
- Was hast du ausgeleert?
Ich wollte schauen, was drin ist.
- Wolltest du schauen, was drin ist?
Und was war denn drin?
Nudeln.
Ja, wahrscheinlich waren sogar
Nudeln drin beim Abendessen.
Mami weiss das nicht mal mehr.
Aber heisses Wasser war drin.
Heisses Wasser ... war drin.
Wir haben sie zu zweit
in der Badewanne abgeduscht -
meine Freundin und ich.
Wir zogen ihr das Pyjama aus,
das sie anhatte.
Für mich war das
der schlimmste Moment:
ein Kind, das in der Badewanne ist,
die Ärmchen hochstreckt,
man will es in den Arm nehmen,
es geht ihm nicht gut.
Der erste Reflex ist, es in den Arm
zu nehmen, doch man kann nicht.
Denn man muss es ja abduschen.
Das sind Bilder,
die mich bis heute verfolgen.
* Spannende Klänge, Sirenen *
Mit der Ambulanz fuhren Tamara
und die damals hochschwangere
Sandra Schmied ins Kinderspital.
20 % von Tamaras Haut
waren stark verbrüht.
Auch bei ihr mussten die Chirurgen
gesunde Haut auf die verbrannten
Stellen transplantieren.
Einem schwer brandverletzten Kind
wie Tamara
müssen Ärzte und Pflegefachfrauen
regelmässig die Verbände wechseln.
Am Anfang erhält das Kind dafür
eine Narkose,
die Schmerzen
wären sonst traumatisierend.
* Spannende Klänge *
Die Wunden auf Isabel Sahlis Haut
sind längst geheilt.
Die Narben jedoch bleiben.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wenn Isabel unter die Leute geht,
zieht sie Blicke auf sich.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Solche Blicke
fallen mir eigentlich gar nicht auf.
Ich habe wie gelernt,
das auszuschalten -
vielleicht gibt es auch weniger.
Darum stresst es mich auch nicht.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich sehen würde,
dass mich jemand so anschaut ...
Ich lasse es wie nicht an mich ran,
denn sonst
würde es mich schon mehr bedrücken.
Psychologe Markus Landolt
und sein Team haben erforscht,
dass Kinder andere Kinder mit Narben
als weniger intelligent
und unsympathischer einschätzen.
Für die Betroffenen
ist es schon sehr schwierig,
wenn sie
so negative Reaktionen bemerken.
Und es ist nicht nur das.
Es gibt auch Studien
bei Erwachsenen, die belegen,
dass sie weniger häufig
einen Job bekommen,
schlechter verdienen.
Es ist wirklich ein Nachteil,
der sich durchs ganze Leben zieht.
Das ist gemein, es ist wie
eine Zusatzstrafe für diesen Unfall,
für den sie ja nichts können.
Hallo, Isabel.
Du bist in der Camouflage-
Sprechstunde,
um deine Narben zu überschminken.
Es geht darum, mit zwei, drei Farben
deinen Hautton zu treffen.
Also den Bräunungsgrad
und deinen Grundton.
Das muss ich
an deiner hellsten Stelle ...
Hier hast du eine intakte Stelle.
Ich ziehe mit ein paar Farben
einige Linien.
Wir mischen das zusammen, bis wir
denken, dass etwas passen könnte.
Kannst du mir
deinen Unterarm so hinlegen?
Ich ziehe ein paar Linien
mit Farben,
bei denen du vielleicht denkst,
sie passen nicht.
Nicht erschrecken!
Ich gleiche es aus
mit deinem Bräunungsgrad
und dann sollte man etwas finden.
Wirst du sehr braun im Sommer?
- Nein.
Ist dein Braun eher rötlich oder ...
- Eher rötlich.
Gut.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Der könnte eigentlich noch passen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass die 61 für drüber
gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Das sieht richtig aus.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Wofür willst du es brauchen?
Jeden Tag?
Oder eher für spezielle Anlässe?
Jeden Tag -
das wäre mir zu aufwendig.
Ich schlafe lieber
so lange wie möglich.
Ich denke, eher ...
Man braucht ... Wahrscheinlich
wirst du mit der Zeit schneller.
Das kann sein.
- Aber das ist schon so.
Es gibt Leute,
die einen am Morgen so sehen,
also ungeschminkt.
Ich finde,
man muss lernen, damit umzugehen.
Man kann sich nicht immer
hinter Make-up verstecken.
Ist es gut?
- Ja.
Super.
Hast du das Gefühl, es nützt?
Ja, es ist schon ...
Meistens sieht man die Rötung stark.
Die ist ziemlich gut abgedeckt.
- Genau, das ist,
damit der erste Blick der Leute
nicht so haften bleibt.
Ist es gut?
- Ja.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Isabel Sahli will Brandmale
und andere Hautauffälligkeiten
erforschen.
Deshalb schreibt sie
ihre Maturarbeit zu diesem Thema
und interviewt
Betroffene und Fachleute.
Auch ihren Kinderchirurgen.
Ich habe Ihnen
die Interviewfragen mitgebracht.
Ich habe sie Ihnen ausgedruckt.
- Vielen Dank.
Ist es okay, wenn ich es aufzeichne?
- Ja, absolut okay.
Was denken Sie
über meine Maturarbeitshypothese,
welche Strategien Leute
mit Hautauffälligkeiten entwickeln?
Darüber haben wir im Team
immer wieder diskutiert,
v.a. mit Psychologen
und Sozialarbeitern:
Wie können wir letztendlich Menschen
helfen, also euch helfen,
die damit leben müssen?
Denn man wird immer etwas sehen,
egal, wie gut es dann aussieht.
Und man kann diesen Menschen
diese Stigmatisierung nicht nehmen,
zu einem gewissem Grad bleibt sie.
Wie geht man damit um?
Ich habe selber
nach all diesen Jahren ...
Im Umgang mit Kindern
und Jugendlichen ist es wichtig,
dass man
einen offensiven Umgang hat.
D.h., dass man dazu steht,
dass es so ist.
Es gibt immer
einen ganz schmalen Pfad
zwischen korrigieren
und akzeptieren.
Es ist wichtig, dass du in deiner
Maturarbeit die These erstellst,
dass ein offener Umgang damit
wichtig ist.
"Ja, ich habe das. Ja, ich werde
angestarrt - wie reagiere ich?"
"Was kann ich sagen,
wenn ich gehänselt werde?"
"Wie kann ich mich wehren?"
Das sind ganz wichtige Faktoren,
um zu lernen, damit umzugehen.
Was wünschen Sie sich
für die Zukunft?
Dass unsere Gesellschaft
weiterhin tolerant ist
gegenüber Menschen,
die andersartig sind.
Ich glaube, es tut der Gesellschaft
gut, wenn sie diese Fähigkeit hat.
Wenn die Menschen
die Fähigkeit haben,
andere Menschen,
die nicht der Norm entsprechen,
zu akzeptieren und so anzunehmen,
wie sie sind.
Denn das hat so starke Auswirkungen
auf unser Zusammenleben -
überhaupt innerhalb
einer Gesellschaft -,
dass ich das
als sehr wichtig erachte.
Ja, sehr schön. Vielen Dank.
Achtung, es geht langsam hoch.
* Pfeifen *
Einmal pro Woche
muss Guus zur Physiotherapie.
So.
Genau, streck dich erst mal!
Richtig weit strecken.
Gähnen! Oh, ist das anstrengend
heute! Richtig strecken!
Die Arme nach oben, komm!
* Stöhnen *
Wie wenn man aufwacht.
Er schläft halt noch.
* Guus schnarcht. *
Und schnarcht furchtbar laut.
* Schnarchen *
Okay, du darfst erst mal schlafen.
Aua!
- Das ist noch der Knoten.
- Entschuldige.
Das ...
- I'm sorry.
Danke schön.
- Bitte schön.
Ja, bäng!
Ich wusste, dass ich jetzt hier
keine Ruhe mehr habe.
Ziel ist,
dass seine Haut dehnbar bleibt
und weniger Operationen nötig sind.
Ich bin der heilige Mann.
Der heilige Mann?
Was für ein heiliger Mann?
Er hat so grosse Augen.
Das sieht eher aus
wie eine Hornisse oder so.
Eine grosse Biene.
- Hallo.
Grosse Biene.
Guus hat keine Lust auf Therapie.
Viel lieber trainiert er.
Allen ein Kompliment:
Eine gute Mannschaftsleistung
über das Ganze betrachtet, auch wenn
es für die einen enttäuschend war.
Jetzt hat dabei halt
der fünfte Platz rausgeschaut.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Wir haben heute das letzte Training.
Nach neun Monaten in Spital und Reha
konnte Guus es kaum erwarten,
wieder Fussball zu spielen.
Seit einem Monat darf er wieder
mit seinem Team aufs Feld:
Seine Kollegen und der Trainer
besuchten ihn in Spital und Reha.
Bei den letzten Partien
fieberte Guus von der Bank aus mit.
Diego.
- Nils!
(Mehrere Jungs) Diego!
Nein, wir haben ihn.
- Nein, wir hatten ihn.
Guus, du darfst nochmals.
Ähm ... ähm ... ähm ... Noel.
Oh, wir haben die Besten.
- Noel, du bist im Tor.
Die Temperatur auf dem Kunstrasen
beträgt 37 °C, aber Guus hält mit.
* Verschiedene Rufe *
* Jubel *
* Sie sprechen holländisch. *
Die Narben brauchen viel Pflege,
damit sie optimal heilen.
Jeden Morgen, jeden Abend ―
2 Std. pro Tag.
Irgendwie findet man die Kraft,
das zu machen.
Ich mache es für Guus, damit es
für ihn nachher besser wird.
Manchmal geht es ihm auch wirklich
nicht sogut , weil er es satt hat.
Aber wir wissen,
wofür wir es machen,
und das gibt auch wieder Kraft,
um weiterzugehen.
Die andere Hand!
Gut.
Zum Schlafen muss Guus den Kompres-
sionsanzug nach wie vor tragen.
Hey!
Hinlegen!
- Oh, là,là.
Ja.
Now.
- Ja? Okay.
Nein. Now. Nein. Now.
- Bitte.
(Lachend) Nein. Now. Nein. Now.
Now ... nein.
- Okay.
Hältst du es?
Deine Haare.
(Flüsternd) Darf ich sie schneiden?
- Nein.
Warum nicht?
- Weil du es nicht darfst.
Wie?
- Weil es verboten ist.
Steh still! So.
- Nein.
Hoppla. So.
* Melancholische Klänge *
So.
Gute Nacht.
* Tamara singt.*
* Tamara singt ein Kinderlied. *
* Die Eltern lachen. *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Im Hochsommer darf Tamara nur kurz an
die Sonne, und nicht zur Mittagszeit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Tamara, schau mal! Das ist, als du
dich ganz frisch verbrüht hast.
Und hier? Und hier?
Hier bekamst du den Verband.
Da kamen wir frisch nach Zürich.
Kenne ich nicht.
- Kennst du nicht?
Doch, sicher.
- Die kennst du.
Musstest du weinen?
Warum wohl?
- Ich weiss auch nicht.
Es gefiel dir nicht.
Endlich ist es vorbei,
endlich kann man sich gut bewegen.
Für mich ging es
tagsüber immer sehr gut.
Man konnte etwas machen,
war beim Kind.
Im Spital läuft immer etwas.
Nachts kamen diese Bilder
immer wieder.
Ich habe es immer wieder geträumt,
hatte den Unfallhergang
immer wieder vor meinen Augen.
D.h., ich habe diesen Unfall
immer wieder, x-mal durchgemacht.
Und ja, ich hörte einfach sehr oft
diese Schreie und sah das Mädchen,
das ich
nicht in den Arm nehmen konnte.
Das war emotional sehr anstrengend,
auch in der Nacht.
Man ist dann
wie nie zur Ruhe gekommen.
Dass sich Sandra Vorwürfe macht,
ist klar.
Ich probiere,
ihr so gut es geht zu versichern,
dass sie keine Schuld daran trägt.
Das tut sie nicht.
Es ist einfach passiert.
Auch Monate
nach seinem schweren Unfall
muss Guus
immer wieder operiert werden.
Dieses Mal
ist es ein ambulanter Eingriff.
Guus darf am Abend nach Hause.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen:
Ein Einjähriges verdoppelt
seine Körperoberfläche
innerhalb kürzester Zeit,
zwei, drei Jahren.
Dann kommt
die verpflanzte Haut nicht mit.
Guus ist ein Schulkind,
er macht das nicht so schnell,
aber doch
in einem ordentlichen Tempo.
So wird man wohl in einem Jahr
am Hals sehen, dass es zu eng wird.
Hoi.
- Schau, wer da ist!
Wer klopft da einfach? Hoi, hoi.
Grüezi.
- Hallo.
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Hallo.
- Guten Tag.
Hallo. Hoi.
Er ist plötzlich etwas schüchtern.
- Plötzlich.
Wir haben noch diese Kleber drauf.
- Willst du es so machen?
Er sagte, es sei vielleicht besser.
Die einen mögen die Maske weniger,
die anderen die Stichlein.
Ich mag die Stichlein weniger.
- Dann musst du es genau so sagen.
Nein, du kannst dann nichts mehr
sagen, wir müssen es sagen.
Nicht wahr?
Du musst dir noch
einen Duft aussuchen.
Ich weiss sowieso schon, was.
- Weisst du es schon?
Erdbeere?
- Ja.
Das ist der beste.
Gehen wir mal ins Zimmer, Guus?
- Bis später, Guus.
Vor der Operation lässt Guus noch
seine Haut aus dem Labor untersuchen.
Diese Daten sind für die Studie,
an der er teilnimmt, wichtig.
Eigentlich messen wir schon,
wie elastisch deine Haut ist.
Wir sind auch sehr gespannt,
wie deine neue Haut aussieht.
Wie elastisch sie schon ist.
Und dann schauen wir mal eben.
Da war die Haut, oder?
Genau da.
Dann mache ich das etwas sauber.
So.
Vielleicht hilft mir Leif dann noch.
* Summen *
Du machst das super, Guus.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Aber die Auswertung
muss ich noch machen.
Ich werde dir Bescheid geben, okay?
Die Eltern von Guus teilen sich auf:
Der Vater bringt ihn jeweils zur
Operation, die Mutter holt ihn ab.
Dies ist für Guus
die 31. Operation seit dem Unfall.
* Melancholische Klänge *
* Schluchzen *
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Der Papa bleibt bei dir,
bis du eingeschlafen bist.
* Guus weint. *
Hey, Guus, wir haben extra
Alonso für dich eingeflogen.
* Guus lacht. *
Super. Du machst das super.
Alles gut.
Papa bleibt die ganze Zeit.
Noch mal ganz tief Luft holen!
- Gut.
Gut so.
So, jetzt musst du
nochmals ganz viel Luft holen!
Ja, ganz fest.
Ganz tief.
* Piepen *
Jetzt können Sie rausgehen.
- Ja.
Vielen Dank für die Hilfe.
Bis später. Danke schön.
* Regelmässiges Piepen *
* Melancholische Klänge *
* Unverständliches Flüstern *
Marlies Sahli, Isabels Mutter,
wühlt der Unfall ihrer
jüngsten Tochter noch immer auf.
Vor der Kamera
kann sie nicht darüber reden.
Ich hatte immer
eine sehr unterstützende Familie.
Meine Mutter
war sehr viel bei mir im Spital,
war mir eine grosse Unterstützung,
was ich auch schätze.
Für mich ist es dann auch schwierig:
Ich kann mich eigentlich nur
in meine Situation versetzen.
Ich habe selber keine Kinder.
Sie sagt oft: "Das versteht man
nur, wenn man Mutter ist."
Es ist schon schlimm,
wenn du siehst,
was deine Tochter
alles durchmachen muss.
Was für Narben sie
mit sich tragen muss.
Ich mache auch viel mit Freunden,
was sie auch freut -
dass ich
ein derart gutes Umfeld habe
und mich nicht
zu Hause verstecke,
sondern eben rausgehe.
Isabel hat ihre Freunde
zu einem Sommerfest eingeladen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ein herzliches Umfeld
und eine liebende Familie ―
das ist für brandverletzte Kinder
besonders wichtig.
Es ist nicht, ob ich jetzt
10 oder 30 % verbrannt bin,
sondern es kommt drauf an, wie gut
mich meine Familie unterstützt.
All diese Familien,
die liebend, unterstützend sind,
das Kind
in dieser schweren Zeit begleiten,
die haben definitiv einen Vorteil.
Das ist auch belegt.
Darum machen wir alles,
um die Familie zu stützen,
denn auf Dauer
ist die Familie entscheidend.
Eine Familie, die das nicht kann,
sei das, weil sie
vorbestehende Konflikte hat
oder weil sie wegen des Unfalls
allzu sehr stark leidet,
weil sie sich Schuldzuweisungen
machen usw.,
dort wird es schwierig -
auch für das Kind.
Sandra Schmied hat sich
für eine Therapie entschieden.
Noch immer sind ihre Schuldgefühle
zu stark. Es ist ihre dritte Sitzung.
Also, Frau Schmied,
wir haben uns, glaube ich,
vor etwa zwei Wochen
das letzte Mal gesehen.
Der Unfall ist eineinhalb Jahre her,
und wir haben gesagt,
das Thema Schuldgefühle
ist immer noch
etwas aktuell bei Ihnen.
Nicht nur etwas.
Noch sehr aktuell.
Erzählen Sie mal:
Wie haben diese Schuldgefühle,
die Sie seit dem Unfall plagen,
Sie beeinflusst
im Umgang mit Tamara und Thomas,
mit Ihren beiden Kindern?
Es beeinflusste mich insofern,
als dass ich merkte,
dass ich sie überbehüten wollte.
Es darf nichts mehr passieren.
Ich hatte es auch etwas
mit der Pflege.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass es niemand so gut kann wie ich.
Es ist wie mein Job.
Ich machte einen Fehler,
der zu diesem Unfall führte.
Ich muss es jetzt wiedergutmachen.
Was wir manchmal machen,
ist, über die Schuldgefühle ...
Das hier ist der Schuldkuchen.
Nun kann man einzeichnen,
zu wie viel Prozent
etwas zu etwas beiträgt.
Jetzt bin ich neugierig bei Tamara.
Wie würden Sie den Schuldkuchen
beim Unfall zeichnen?
Überlegen Sie sich das mal!
Das finde ich extrem schwierig.
Auf der einen Seite würde ich sagen,
es sind 100 %,
weil ich den Topf dort hinstellte.
- Ja, aber ...
Wenn ich jetzt
allein von dem Moment ausgehe,
an dem ich den Topf hinstelle,
wäre der Schuldkuchen relativ klein,
sage ich jetzt.
Wie viel sind das?
20 % - oder nicht einmal.
Nicht einmal.
- 15 %. Okay.
Dann kommen viele Zufälle hinzu.
Wir waren in den Ferien
und hatten eine derart kleine Küche,
dass wir auf die Idee kamen,
den Topf überhaupt
auf den Tisch zu stellen.
Und jemand entschied,
dass man dorthin in die Ferien geht
und in diese Wohnung.
- Das kann man ins Unendliche ...
Ja, es braucht ganz viel.
Der Kuchen zeigt auch,
dass der Teil, den Sie verursachten,
nur ein kleiner ist.
Wenn man sich das rational überlegt.
Das ändert die Gefühle nicht.
Das hilft einem immer wieder,
wenn man gerade grübelt,
sich sagt:
"Welchen Fehler machte ich da?"
Man muss sich
immer wieder bewusst machen,
wie dieser Schuldkuchen aussieht.
Es ist nie nur der letzte Moment,
die letzte Handlung, die man machte,
die zu diesem Ereignis führt.
Sondern es ist
eine Riesenmenge an Dingen,
die nur, wenn sie alle
in dieser Reihenfolge passieren,
letztlich
zu diesem Ereignis führen.
Ich erwartete nicht,
dass Sie das gleich so einzeichnen.
Ich dachte, Sie machen
einen viel grösseren Teil,
den Sie als Ihre Schuld betrachten.
Dass Sie das so machen, heisst,
dass Sie das rein kognitiv schon
sehr stark relativieren können.
Niemand - gar niemand -
macht Ihnen Vorwürfe.
Der einzige Weg, das zu überwinden,
ist, sich selbst zu verzeihen,
dass dieser Moment passiert ist.
Und auch zu wissen: Das ist relativ.
Ganz abklingen ...
Es ist wie mit Tamaras Narben,
die werden immer sichtbar bleiben.
Ich denke, meine Schuldgefühle
werden immer da sein.
Sie werden nie verschwinden.
- Nein, nie.
Es wird vielleicht besser,
hoffe ich zumindest.
Aber ich denke nicht,
dass sie verschwinden.
Das denke ich auch nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass diese Schuld-
gefühle ein Ausmass haben,
das Sie in Ihrem Leben
nicht gross beeinträchtigt.
Sei es im Umgang mit den Kindern
oder mit sich selbst.
Mehrmals pro Jahr laden
die Spezialisten vom Kinderspital
Kinder mit Hautauffälligkeiten
und ihre Familien ein.
(Mann) Hoi.
Grüezi.
- Hoi.
Grüezi, Frau Lanz.
- Grüezi, Frau Lanz.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
* Stimmengwirr *
Nein!
- Machen wir keinen Sticker dran?
Nein.
- Dann eben nicht.
Sie sollen sich austauschen können -
Erfahrungen teilen,
Wissen weitergeben.
Kühlein.
- Kühlein.
Rehlein.
- Und Rehlein und ...
Tamaras Familie geht es besser.
Seitdem Sandra Schmied
ihre Schuldgefühle
mithilfe des Psychologen verarbeitet,
sind die Albträume fast weg.
Isabel schloss ihre Maturarbeit
mit Bravour ab.
Sie möchte Medizin studieren.
Im Frühling wird sie
ihr erstes Praktikum absolvieren -
im Kinderspital
bei ihren früheren Ärzten.
Guus hat sich schnell
von seiner Operation erholt.
Er kann sich wieder besser bewegen.
Auch Mutter Josée ist erleichtert.
Sie hat
nach dem erschütternden Unfall
mit einer Traumatherapie begonnen
und diese vor Kurzem abgeschlossen.
Für mich persönlich finde ich,
dass man die Zeit,
die man miteinander verbringt,
viel mehr schätzt.
Dass man Wert darauf legt, dass
das Familienleben sehr wichtig ist
und dass Arbeit Arbeit ist.
Sie gehört dazu,
aber wenn die Familie zusammen ist,
kann man so schöne Momente haben,
und die soll man auch haben.
Ich finde das ... Ich schätze das
extrem und lege viel Wert darauf.
* Knistern *
Ich stehe jetzt stärker im Leben,
bin älter geworden
und weiss, was ich will.
Mich bringt man
nicht so rasch aus dem Konzept.
Ich kann gut
mit schwierigen Situationen umgehen.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl ... ja ...
Ich weiss, dass das Leben
schwierig sein kann
und ein kleiner Moment
das ganze Leben verändern kann.
Ich denke,
ich habe schon viel dazugelernt,
weil es mich auch verändert hat.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Der schwere Unfall
hat Isabel Sahli zwar gezeichnet,
ihr Leben jedochdominiert er nicht mehr.
* Stimmengewirr *